this is a car now pay attention please
windscreen bulletproof that other side
and the rear windows now I'll tell you
what I'm going to do I can give it to
you with a heck of a sealant get your
John Hancock you're on your way we're
the keys
[Applause]
consider the car crews commute sit in
traffic take a road trip make out in the
backseat break down get pulled over push
the pedal to the metal race chase and
crash
the car has a ubiquitous place in cinema
but why is cinema obsessed with the
automobile one of the most fetishized
objects in film the car is represented
more often and more diversely than any
other form of transportation but to call
the car transportation is to
misunderstand its role and film entirely
the car movie and the large car chase
action set-pieces are probably what leap
immediately to mind when thinking about
cars and movies and you could make whole
video essays about those things alone
but the space the car has carved out for
itself in the movies is much larger than
that how's your attorney I advise you to
rent a very fast car with no top a car
is a costume a character's car can tell
you a lot about them before they even
speak in Nightcrawler Lu's car is the
main way were shown that he's gaining
success in boyhood the car the father
drives tips us off to the fact that he's
the funny responsible dad and when he
trades it in later in the film it's an
indication of personal change so this is
like Danny's car and and you drive the
GTO
I didn't even a baby seen that thing
but I had to sell it a car can be an
extension of a character and the
Darjeeling Limited the brothers attempts
to retrieve their father's broken-down
car and take this car Ellis traits their
dysfunction in the midst of their grief
get back in that car dude where is your
car in the big lebowski the destruction
of the dudes car parallels the
out-of-control spiral of the story in
taxi driver Travis bickel's taxi is a
high horse for him to sit upon it is
what separates him from what he calls
scum of the streets
[Music]
the car is a location the interior is a
dramatic stage the characters all face
the audience and the scenes that unfold
inside a car are as varied as the humans
that occupy them Jimmy take this job
please but they was witnesses seen us
redeemed that's not the issue Delmer
even if it did put your square with the
Lord the state of Mississippi's a little
more this forced intimacy is instant
fodder for what cinema loves to examine
but equally interesting to the prying
eyes of the film camera are the
inescapable silences
our vibrations were getting nasty but
why was there no communication in this
car and the arguments your drivers
studies you wouldn't let me practice
what else you work or the or the way
that you don't work you're not even
worth state tuition Christine cars trap
us in a box with other people who can't
leave at least without hurting
themselves everybody already you better
come with us maybe yeah take the ride
with a favor no listen I really like you
but I there's the tension of being
forced into the back seat with a few
unsavory characters or the joy of being
crammed in together with somebody's a
car can separate a character from their
surroundings
it's a portable space that we own it's a
representation of our individualism of
our personal freedom in the car you get
to go where you want to go your hands
are on the wheel you feel you control
your destiny and you get to put your
music on
[Music]
that space provides a perhaps false
sense of privacy and shelter from the
outside world
criminals feel free to talk business
myself or mr. pink you to take the
manager in the back and make him give
you the diamonds we're there for those
stones period you might try to hide in
one from outside danger but that space
can be invaded revealing how fragile a
shell of protection it really is and the
freedom the car gives us can leave us
vulnerable
[Applause]
the car is a location includes more than
just the interior the archipelago of
cars in a parking lot our personal
islands for people to gather around for
conversation leaning at someone's car
window puts you on the line between
stranger and friend waiting to be
welcomed in or evaluating whether you'd
even want to enter a character might
remove someone from their car as an
attempt to remove that person from their
life or drive away to achieve the same
effect the car can symbolize youth
grasping for maturity and trying to
enter adulthood and Rushmore Max's
constant invasion of the adults cars is
an image of his attempts to be a part of
their world in ladybird ladybird need
for others to drive her around is an
image of her dependence and then
eventual gaining of independence what
happened
a car accident
[Music]
[Music]
the car is violent the trauma of an
accident has been used endlessly as a
dramatic tool a visual shorthand it's a
favorite of the flashback vandalizing a
car isn't an attack on the object it's
an attack on the person who drives that
car and the car itself can become a way
to act out in The Godfather there's a
motif of violence in association with
cars
perhaps representing how changing times
are presenting challenges for the Mafia
maybe the car harnesses some more primal
instinct for the thrill of the chase
it's a mundane and commonplace part of
our lives that can suddenly become a
vehicle of thrill a weapon a gadget or a
detective's tool for investigation
[Music]
gimme enticing to the camera is the
movement of the car
the endless motion of the landscapes
found outside the windows there can be a
dramatic inevitability to this movement
a feeling of something that can't be
undone lock a movie set entirely in a
car during a single trip uses the
finality of each mile driven to build
tension okay listen I will be back for
that something's come up I can't get out
of it
but that movement can also come to a
screeching halt leaving people stuck
unable to get where they want to go
creating some of the conflict and
obstacles that every character needs
three months left seven o'clock
in your window down
the obsession runs deep
even in our fantasies we cling to the
image of the car we use it to traverse
through time and even when society has
been utterly destroyed the car remains
we consistently humanized the car and
imbue upon it a personality and self
making one of the few pieces of
technology we seem to consistently
anthropomorphize in our media scenes and
cars have been shot in a variety of ways
throughout film history but there
emerges what I see as two primary
approaches in the first and the most
common the camera assumes an omniscient
presence around the vehicle impossibly
floating in and around the car to
provide the best compositions the second
approach rising to prominence through
the directors of the French new-wave
felt it was unnatural to place a camera
on the outside looking in through the
windshield
is to put the camera in the car making
the viewer just another passenger
filmmakers have gone to great lengths to
film the car it presents a challenge but
one that filmmakers are obviously
willing to overcome I think the
diversity of things that a car can be or
represent makes it a perfect tool for
filmmakers certainly Hollywood's
location in a city where cars are a
necessity has impacted the presence of
cars in the movies le writers write cars
into films because cars are part of
their lives had the world's empire of
film been located in a city with good
public transportation maybe things would
have been different
cinema is the technological sibling of
the car born of the same era neither
knows of a time without the other I have
to wonder how cinema will be affected by
the way the car changes will the arrival
of self-driving cars be like the cell
phone an obstacle that writers have to
learn how to write for something that
challenges the conventions of how
transportation is displayed whether or
not it continues to be the car has been
a vital piece of cinematic storytelling
in the movies a car is never just a car
thank you so much for watching huge
thank you to my patreon supporters I
couldn't do this without them this
channel is supported by viewers like you
so if you want to support my content
please consider becoming a patron if
you're a youtuber or a filmmaker and you
like the music in this video check out
art list I license all my music through
them and if you use the link in the
description you'll get an extra two
months for free when you sign up